et on va faire de toi t'as le bonjour du
parti on se retrouve là bas
[Musique]
c'est le but
[Applaudissements]
alors les rôles au mans stéphane javalet
ceinture va te mettre de l'autre côté
ici tu vois c'est de la vraie pas vrai
c'est la vraie pas tout c'est de la
vraie peinture gare oui allô allô oui
c'est très simple mais qu'est ce tu fais
là je les avais failli me fie à ce qu'on
fait c'est moi qui fais tu vas oui il va
donc normal il reste là bas mais toi tu
va mettre tes mains comme ceux ci nous
apprend et je les vois pas si je leur
avais justement tu vas prendre un
pinceau d'accord tu veux je veux tu veux
je vais devoir te dire quelles mains
d'accord il ya des pinceaux avec toi tu
auras un dans chaque main tenant un
pinceau un pinceau un oui discrètement
10 rico je vais je veux tu vas devoir me
dire quelles mains si je tombe sur la
moria de la peinture tu ne mettras un
petit peu sur la gueule j'aime bien ce
jeu ouais mais les jurés ne survient et
ben ça sera bien d'accord et moi je
gérais j'ai rien bas vont investir bonne
averse ça tu veux qu'on commence par
mois oui oui je suis quand même à temps
si ça te dérange pas un chien groupe
hertz est ouest comme ça tu comprends
alors est-ce que vous d'un petit
ingénieur du son quelque chose ici non
voilà alors dis-moi quelle main et
battant j'enlève ma vais-je préféra tard
est inquiète
oui bah si je te connais quand même un
chauffeur qui mois qu'elle ment et ben
je dirais la droite benjamin change pas
entre laquelle montre à 7,6 et celles ci
allaient où le pinceau
je pense qu'il est donc je pense qu'il
est là dans dix sept marins
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attends de la vraie peinture fait la
même chose on va trouver quelle main
attention je ne te regarde
mais est-ce qu'on brade oui on peut voir
si je triche lada s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
enfin ils te font mais c'est la novation
regarde que tout alors qu'elle m'a non
non tu l'aimé bien mais tu dois les
mettre
cela est bien de les mettre bien on voit
là bas le long du corps là c'est pareil
non gg peut pas changer le pinceau donc
je te jure c'est bon de dire pour moi je
choisis je choisi celle là
[Rires]
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
j'adorais notre couleur une autre
couleur pour le plaza
non ça ne va pas mais on ne regarde pas
je suis want you win oui oui tu tues de
chance maintenant on te voit
ok ok qu'est ce que tu veux je te dise
dis-moi lama choisi tout la main où il
ya le pinceau où il n'y a pas de
changement au niveau du jaudy la main
que tu veux celle ci la suite avait
changé
[Rires]
sept jours du patron revanche talk show
de la fia la plaza cas ça fait plaisir
de jouer à ce jeu devant ton papa est
bon aussi il est courant de faire des
études pour faire sérieux quelles mains
l'ads à plat de nouilles
salah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les imoca poggio
[Applaudissements]
il est en colère mais pas peu dire voilà
voilà voilà la plata
[Applaudissements]
l'adversaire